I'm super excited to take a look at this
today it's a paper written by Alan Turing
in 1950 and it's called Computing Machinery
and Intelligence. In it Alan Turing talks
about the imitation game for the first
time which has come to be known as the
Turing test. It's a famous idea in computer
science and you'll hear it mentioned often
but until now I had never actually read the
original paper where it was explained by Alan
Turing himself and I'm glad that I finally
did I think anyone interested in artificial
intelligence would benefit from reading the
original paper so let's take a look at it.
Turing starts off by considering
the question 'can machines think?'
but figures that actually that question
is way too ambiguous. The words machine
and think are too ambiguous to define
and instead he comes up with a game,
the imitation game, which he thinks will be
equivalent to asking if machines can think.
The next paragraph surprised me it's the
first mention of what this imitation game
is but there's no robots involved yet. It is an
interrogator trying to tell the difference between
a man and a woman, I don't think that's
the kind of game you would see included
in a scientific paper these days. He says the
game is played with three people A is a man,
B a woman and C is the interrogator. The
interrogator stays in a room apart from
the other two. The object of the game for
the interrogator is to determine which of
the other two is the man and which is the woman.
In order to tell this difference the interrogator
could apparently ask questions such as will X,
referring to one of the unknown participants,
please tell me the length of his or her hair?
This communication would ideally be written so
that the tones of voice don't give anything away.
The man is working to deceive the interrogator
by imitating a woman whereas the real woman is
working to help the interrogator make the right
identification. Now here is the important part
where the game evolves we now ask the question
what will happen when a machine takes the part
of participant A, the man, in this game? Will the
interrogator decide wrongly as often when the game
is played like this as he does when the game is
played between a man and a woman? These questions
replace our original, 'Can machines think?'
There are two ways that this can be interpreted.
One is the literal interpretation where the
man is replaced by a machine but nothing
else about the game changes meaning that
the machine has now taken over the man's
role of pretending to be a woman. In this
version of the game we have a man trying to
convince an interrogator that he is a woman,
competing against a machine that is doing the
same and trying to see which one can imitate a
woman better. This is a bit of an odd question
and throws the game into the complicated world
of gender identity and expression but it is the
most literal interpretation of Turing's words.
The benefit of interpreting the game like this
is that it disguises the participation of the
machine. The interrogator just thinks they
are trying to tell the difference between a
man and a woman and they don't know that
machines are involved at all so they are
less biased and less on the lookout for
questions that would trip up a machine.
But this isn't the standard interpretation of
Turing's words, the more popular understanding
is that when Turing says that participant a is
replaced by a machine it is assumed that the goal
of the game also changes. It's no longer about
pretending to be a woman but is about pretending
to be a human full stop. The interrogator is no
longer picking between male and female for the
participants, instead they are choosing between
machine and human. This interpretation seems to
be more in line with comments that Turing later
makes about ways to compare humans and machines.
Things go totally off the rails in this next
section where Turing is trying to define the
requirements to enter a machine into the game.
He seems to be a little bit worried that a team
of engineers will say they've made a machine but
actually just enter a human that they made into
the competition and so I just have to read you
this next part. He says one might for instance
insist that the team of engineers should be of
all one sex. This would not really be satisfactory
for it is probably possible to rear a complete
individual from a single cell of the skin say
of a man. To do so would be a feat of biological
technique deserving of the highest praise but we
would not be inclined to regard it as the case
of constructing a thinking machine. This prompts
us to abandon the requirement that every kind of
technique should be permitted. So you're allowed
to enter a machine that you make but you can't
clone yourself or make a baby and enter that. He
settles on saying that only digital computers
will be allowed to take part in our game.
He says there are already a number of
digital computers in working order.
The digital computers in 1950 still looked
nothing like the digital computers that we
know today but he says he's not asking
whether the computer is available at
present would do well but whether there are
imaginable computers which would do well.
And now we get to the real juicy part of this
paper Alan Turing first shares his own opinion
on the matter he says that he believes that in
about 50 years time which would be about the year
2000 it would be possible to program computers to
play the imitation game so well that an average
interrogator would not have a more than 70 chance
of making the correct identification after five
minutes of questioning. He believes that the
original question, 'can machines think?' is
too meaningless to deserve discussion but that
by the end of the century one will be able to
speak of machines thinking without expecting to
be contradicted. Large language models that we
have now like GPT-3 might be the kind of thing
that Alan Turing was trying to imagine would
succeed at his imitation game and I think he did
a pretty good job of estimating what it would be
able to do but his second point that by around
the year 2000 people would consider machines
thinking I don't think has come true yet. ChatGPT
might do well at the imitation game but I don't
agree with Turing's point that that would mean
that humans would then consider it thinking,
in fact what we've really seen is that we
continuously move the goal posts for what
we consider a thinking machine to be able to
do. I don't think that for us now being able
to mimic human speech in an interrogation would
be enough. My guess is that we don't ever want
to consider machines thinking and so as they
approach any arbitrary test that we put before
them we'll come up with a new one that is more
difficult and that we consider to be more human.
Turing doesn't really have a lot of evidence
that he can present to back up his claim that
he thinks a machine will be able to do well
at his imitation game so instead he tries to
imagine every possible point someone could have
to try and say that machines will never think
or that machines will never do well at this
game. To do this Turing has to put himself
in the shoes of people who don't believe
in his work in the same way that he does
and it's pretty impressive that he's able to
do this. He comes up with nine objections.
The first one is okay maybe you can make an
impressive machine but it will never be able to
think because thinking is a function of a human's
immortal Soul. Turing his is not so impressed with
this argument and basically says that if God
is Almighty he can give a soul to whoever or
whatever he wants to he could give a soul to an
elephant or he could give a soul to a machine.
Okay but what if this is all too dreadful to
think about and we don't want to know about it,
the heads and the sand objection. In
a kind of cold response to this Turing
says I do not think that this argument
is sufficiently substantial to require
refutation, consolation would be more appropriate.
Okay but what about the fundamental limitations
of mathematics? In our current understanding
of mathematics there are logical statements
that can lead to contradictions or paradoxes
given that a digital computer will never be
able to do everything. That there will be some
questions to which it will either give a wrong
answer or fail to give an answer at all. Since
machines are built upon logical systems they
have a disability to which the human intellect
is not subject. Turing says that the superiority
we feel in this area is actually Just an illusion,
that we too give wrong answers based
upon our own flawed logical systems.
A pretty strong objection is the argument from
consciousness. Now he has to be pretty clever
to come up with counterpoints to this objection
because it's claiming that yeah okay a machine
might be able to write a sonnet for example
but until you can prove that it actually has
understood what it's written well then that
doesn't count as thinking. To satisfy someone
who thinks in this way you would need to prove
that the machine actually did have some kind of
deep understanding of what it was able to produce.
This is a problem for humans too this is why if
you write a thesis you might be asked to do
a Viva or an oral exam where a professor will
ask you questions about your work and you have to
defend why you made the decisions that you did and
prove by answering questions that you understand
your work. Turing writes up one such exam for a
machine and to be honest this looks really
similar to the kind of dialogue and defense
I was able to get out of ChatGPT when I asked it
why it made certain word choices in a poem that it
had generated. Just like Alan Turing predicted,
machines can already do a pretty convincing job
of defending their work but this still doesn't
necessarily mean that they can think and that
they truly understand it. Philosophically we face
a conundrum that none of us have any evidence that
anyone other than ourselves is thinking but
for the sake of our own individual sanity we
have to assume that other people in the world
can think without us being able to enter their
mind and prove it. Any questions or debate around
consciousness are pretty difficult because there
is still a lot of mystery to it but having done a
pretty decent job at giving some counter arguments
here Turing has the confidence to go on and
then counteract another difficult objection.
This one says that sure you can make a clever
machine but you will never be able to make it
do X. I think my favorite part of this whole
paper is the ideas that Turing gives for what
X could be. He considers that you might never
be able to make a machine that can be kind,
resourceful, beautiful, friendly, have initiative,
have a sense of humor, tell right from wrong,
make mistakes, fall in love, enjoy strawberries
and cream, make some one fall in love with it,
learn from experience, use words
properly, be subject of its own thought,
have as much diversity of behavior as
a human or to do something really new.
This is my favorite part of the paper because
considering each of these things in turn and
wondering if a machine could ever be able to
do them is something that I find really fun
and interesting to think about. Turing says
it's perfectly reasonable to expect machines
to be able to make mistakes, that even a
process of scientific induction can lead
to erronous results and thinking about the
claim that a machine could not be subject
of its own thought Turing says that
by observing the results of its own
behavior it could modify its own programs so
as to achieve some purpose more effectively.
He says these are possibilities of the
near future rather than utopian dreams.
Number six is Lady Lovelace's objection. Ada
Lovelace lived long before Alan Turing so the part
of her that is represented in this section is not
literally her responding and objecting to Turing,
rather it is Turing including something
that she had written in her time back
when she was working on the Analytical
Engine with Charles Babbage, an awesome
giant steam-powered mechanical computer. She
said of the Analytical Engine that it has no
pretensions to originate anything, that it can
do whatever we know how to order it to perform.
A way to interpret this could be to say
that a machine could never do anything
really new or never take us by surprise but
perhaps it is very understandable that when
Ada Lovelace wrote this statement she didn't
have much reason to believe that this would
ever be possible. Her and Babbage were under no
obligation to claim all that could be claimed. We
could challenge this idea by considering
that there is nothing new under the sun.
Who can be certain that original work that
he has done was not simply the growth of the
seed planted in him by teaching or the
effect of following well-known general
principles? Turing also notes that machines
take him by surprise with great frequency.
Argument 7 explores the idea that you
could consider our brain and nervous
system to be continuous whereas a
machine would be discrete and asks
can a discrete state machine built
on just math ever a mimic a brain
with complex neurons. Turing thinks
it can come pretty close to doing so.
Argument 8 says that thinking will look pretty
different for a human and a machine because
our behavior is not based on a rigid set of
rules. We think that machines are governed by
laws and we are not, therefore we are better
than machines. We might not have rigid rules
of conduct or behavior but we do have the laws
of physics and our bodies are bound by those.
In that way you could consider our bodies a kind
of machine and we also can't guarantee ourselves
that we don't follow some complete laws of
behavior because in the spirit of science
you'll never reach a point where we could say
that we've searched enough and there are no laws.
Number nine I'd never heard anyone mention
until I read it here in the paper and it's
given plenty of space here so I'm not sure if
that means Alan Turing thought a lot about it
and took it seriously or what was going on but
number nine is the argument from extrasensory
perception. It includes a line saying that
unfortunately the statistical evidence at
least for telepathy is overwhelming. I don't
know exactly what he's referring to with that
but he does seem to consider that his imitation
game does need to take telepathy into account.
He even says this argument is to my mind quite
a strong one. He suggests that to overcome this
you could do something like putting the
competitors into a telepathy proof room.
So now that Turing has finished convincing
everyone that machines should be able to
do well at this imitation game the next big
question is how to make such a machine. The
section here is Turing at his visionary best,
it's him imagining a way to build a machine
and teach a machine all it knows to be good at
imitating a human. This part is interesting, he
says that to best imitate an adult human mind you
should consider three things. One is the initial
state of the mind say at birth. The second is the
education to which it has been subjected and the
third is other experience not to be described
as education to which has been subjected.
So then he goes on to talk about these three
stages and how to replicate them in a machine.
He says it would be easier to build a child's
mind and then teach it all that it needs to
know rather than trying to build and start
with a knowledgeable adult mind. We can see
parallels here to what might be the first ideas
or mentioning of machine learning. Turing mentions
wanting to use punishments and rewards as
a learning process but that you'd have to
ensure that these are unemotional otherwise
the machine would get pretty demotivated if
you're telling it no all the time. There's an
interesting point here that the machine you're
building should include a random element in
its learning. The random element might help
it to have a process that's more analogous to
evolution and the random power of mutations,
and randomness is a key element
of modern machine learning.
Turing says that we may hope that machines
will eventually compete with humans in all
purely intellectual fields and I love
this last line. He says we can only
see a short distance ahead but we can
see plenty there that needs to be done.
So much of what Turing is imagining we've
been lucky to already witness and despite
that many of us are no closer to regarding
machines as thinking entities. I wonder if
the human spirit can ever be put into a test
and what kind of test would satisfy us that
a machine had taken its first steps
onto the continuum of intelligence.
Let me know in the comments what ideas
you have for a variant of this test or
something else that would make you really
stop and reconsider what machines mean to
you. Would you ever feel empathy for one?
And would you ever consider it to think?
Thanks for watching this video and thank you to
my Patreon supporters for making it possible,
a special shout out to today's
Patron cat of the day Dixie